[Applause]
Hello friends it's Naz Perez and Welcome
to our new show more like this where we
bring you more shows to check out like
the ones that you already love today
we've got five bingeable titles based on
your well pretty much everyone's love of
HBO's The Last of Us this adaptation of
the Sony video game franchise Stars
Pedro Pascal as a Smuggler hired to
escort a team played by Bella Ramsey
through a post-apocalyptic United States
this certified Fresh weekly episodic has
been renewed for a second season thank
the zombies in other words you have got
plenty of time on your hands while you
wait for new episodes
thank you
okay here are some other titles to feed
your last of us Cravings starting with
our brand new pick Halo now much like
the last of us this one is based on a
popular video game series and it also
imagines a future with monsters running
rampant Halo follows the cybernetically
enhanced super soldier Master Chief
played by Pablo Schreiber who is
defending Humanity from some very
Advanced and very angry alien races now
along with Schreiber the series also
features Jen Taylor as Cortana reprising
her role from the video game so we'd
love to see that regardless of that
though hardcore Gamers have driven the
audience score down a bit but the first
season is still coming in Fresh on the
Tomato Meter Halo has been renewed for a
second season but for now seven and a
half hours is all you'll need to get
through the first season on Paramount
plus here's lethal
upgradable
and most importantly
controller next is our audience pick in
the flesh this Supernatural drama from
bbc3 is about a teenage zombie that has
been reanimated and treated for
something called partially deceased
syndrome but after he is sent back home
the welcome isn't really warm and things
just keep getting more complicated from
there it was sadly not renewed for a
third season due to budget cuts as BBC
three veered away from being a linear
channel that means eight hours is all
you'll actually need to watch this show
which you can find on Hulu and perhaps
it'll make you wonder how would you
react if a loved one came back into your
life as a half dead zombie you never
know I am a partially deceased syndrome
protected in my entreated state was not
my fault pulling its way in as our
throwback pick is Pushing Daisies so
this show premiered back in 2007 and it
aired for two certified fresh seasons on
ABC and while it does have dead things
involved it's a bit of a break from the
Doom and Gloom of The Last of Us I mean
there's pie involved it stars Lee Pace
as a pie baker who also has the ability
to bring dead things back to life with
his touch besides Reviving his childhood
Crush just for funsies he ultimately
uses a gift for good helping an
investigator solve murder cases by
resurrecting the victim to get their
story and it picked up 17 Emmy Noms in
just two seasons winning seven times
including best supporting actress for
Kristen Chenoweth you'll need to set
aside about 16 hours to binge this one
on HBO Max and then be prepared to one
day be revived from your own death to
tell the story you touch murder victims
you asked who killed them you touched
them again they go back to being dead
and then you collect the reward that's
it in a nutshell for our editors they
have selected Ash versus evil dead so
premiering on Halloween in 2015 this
comedy horror series from stars is about
a chainsaw handed 30-something who
reluctantly becomes Mankind's only hope
against a deadly plague it was
co-created by Sam Raimi and is a sequel
to his certified fresh Evil Dead films
from the 80s with Bruce Campbell
reprising his role as Ash Williams from
the films despite all of its Seasons
coming in at 98 fresh or better the
series was actually canceled after three
seasons although Campbell confirmed in
2022 that an animated Revival is now in
the works to which I say yes please so
you can binge both Evil Dead movies and
all three seasons of the show in about
18 hours and I won't blame you if you
want to replace your hand with a
chainsaw afterwards first thing I gotta
do is see a guy about a book there must
be some spill I can say to undo all this
the other first thing I gotta do is some
cardio because my heart is jackhammering
like a quarterback on prom night and
leaving you with our certified Fresh
Pick The Walking Dead this series began
back in 2010 and ran for 11 straight
fresh Seasons with nine of them coming
in certified fresh I mean that is
impressive trust me it's based on the
comic book series by Robert Kirkman and
it Chronicles a group of survivors in
the months and years after a Zombie
Apocalypse Now the critics consensus has
called it things like consistently
thrilling and an intelligence spin on
the overcrowded zombie sub-genre but if
you're staying focused on just this
series you'll need about 133 hours to
binge the whole thing and if you don't
know the best way to kill a walker by
the end of it then there's just no hope
for you oh I am anymore
and looking for his wife and son
well there you go friends five titles
that you can binge right now if the last
of us is your kind of show and if you're
still with me I guess that it is now we
know your time is valuable so that's why
we're definitely not messing around with
these picks so let us know what you
think of these or if there's another
that you think would have been a good
fit for this list as always don't forget
to find us again for more selections
based on the shows and movies that you
love it's all right here on the Rotten
Tomatoes more like this I'll see you
next time friends
thank you
foreign